-Our first guest tonight
is a Grammy Award-winning
multi-platinum musician.
Her new single "Slow Clap"
is available now,
and she will be performing
for us later tonight.
Please welcome back to the sho
Gwen Stefani.
-Hey!
Thanks for having me back!
-Man, it is so lovely
to see you again.
So, you were here
in October last.
-And the very next day, you an
Blake announced your engagement.
We've since had Blake on.
He told us that you were
actually technically engaged
when we last spoke, but we jus
didn't know it yet.
-Yeah, well, you know, we go
engaged about a week before that
and Blake was like, "Let's not
tell anyone -- let's just, like,
make it ours for a minute," an
I was like, "Yeah, of course."
I was dying to tell everybody,
you know what I mean?
And I knew I was gonna
be on your show, and it was --
I felt really guilty, actually
[ Laughs ]
But look, look! There it is!
There it is, guys!
-Now, that's interesting you
showed it to us,
because Blake said that if w
had been more eagle-eyed,
we would have noticed,
because he claims
you were wearing the ring
in this photo here,
but because you have so much
jewelry...
-Oh! I'm trying to...
I'm, like -- I'm dyslexic
and I'm trying to see,
'cause it's backwards, but..
-Well, I will say, like --
I mean, the very fact
that you have nails like that,
who's gonna notice a ring?
Like, very nice work
to taking our eyes away.
But congratulations.
-Well, we were really excite
to share it, and it was fu
to kind of, like,
hold on to the secret
for a week.
And then finally,
Blake was the one that was like,
"Wait, when are you gonna
tell people?"
I'm, like, "You're the one tha
said not to tell anyone!"
So, anyways, here we are.
We're getting married!
-It is very exciting.
I think that it was probably
wise to keep it to yoursel
for a week, because, of course
people are so excited for yo
that it has become very public
And one of the things that
people are wondering --
who's gonna be
your wedding band?
And now, again,
when Blake was here,
he said that Adam Levine
owed it to you guys.
But then he also said
he wouldn't want Adam to b
the wedding band because h
thinks his music is too boring
And Adam saw that.
-Well... [ Laughs ]
I definitely would love to hav
Adam sing at our wedding.
But you know, the thing is, is
that I feel like
we're not gonna have
a wedding band.
I feel like we're just gonna
go with, like, a playlist.
-I think that's probably -
-We're keeping it very simple.
Really simple.
-It's a lot of pressure
to put on someone
to be a wedding band.
Not just with the two of you
but I'm assuming the guest lis
as well will have
a lot of musicians.
-I think that the guest list
will not have
a lot of musicians.
It's gonna be, like, my mo
and my dad and, like, just
literally gonna be just family
And we are looking forward
to that, though.
It's gonna be fun.
We're gonna make it really fun
But it's not gonna be a big,
like, you know...
It's not like the queen and king
are getting married
or something.
-I want to congratulate you,
as well, on the single.
So, "Slow Clap,"
this was actually --
it sort of came about --
I guess it was born
out of nostalgia
and the fact that you have a son
who is now in his mid-teens.
-You know, I was really --
I wasn't planning to do
new music at all.
And during quarantine,
I think after being, like,
locked down with the kids
and just sort of, like --
just being in that simple kind
of life really did inspire m
to want to be creative again
And watching my son who is
turning 15 this month --
happy birthday, Kingston -
he basically
was discovering music.
You know, he's in eighth grade
It's like that time of your life
where you find music
kind of defines who you are.
And watching him do that made me
think a lot about myself
at that age, discovering
ska and reggae music
and thinking that we were,
like, finding something
that so different and weird,
and we started No Doubt,
you know?
So, yeah, definitely thought
about that, like my roots
when I was making this recor
and trying to figure out..
Like, all of the people
that have been following m
all these years,
like, those people's --
you know, we've been exchangin
love, and I just want
to do something that I think
they would like, you know?
Something that's nostalgic
and familiar, but new.
So, yeah, I was
considering them. [ Chuckles ]
-I mean, it's amazing
to think of --
You know, you obviously ha
this really specific style
when we first started
hearing you,
and now you've had this career
that spans over so many
different genres.
Was it exciting to return
to sort of the first sound
that I guess you guys
fell in love with as a band?
-It's one of those things
where I --
You get to a place
where you're like,
"What kind of music would I make
if I made music now?"
You know what I mean?
And I started thinking
a lot about
just wanting to make a recor
that felt, like,
joyful and happy and upbeat.
That's like the music
that made me feel so good
when I first discovered th
music that kind of defined me.
And I don't know,
I think that, definitely,
music can make you feel great,
you know what I mean?
And that whole
nostalgic thing is so...
I don't know,
important right now.
I think this whole year,
last year has been a time
of, like, reflecting
on yourself.
And so I just thought I need t
make a record.
And everybody that I talked to
that I was collaborating wit
when I started saying I want t
make it like a reggae record
like that kind of a vibe,
they were so into it,
so I thought
I was onto something.
So, it's not done yet.
I'm still writing.
That's so fun about these days
You can just, like, drop singles
and be like, "I just did thi
one last week, check it out.
You know, and it's so differen
than it used to be.
And I love that, 'cause there'
so much more spontaneity.
You know, like, it's just
a song I wrote last week.
Check it out, you know,
if you want to.
If not, don't. [ Laughs ]
-It's really cool.
You talk about this being
a reflective year
and, you know, one of
the upsides of having a career
that's spanned as long as your
is there are all these different
anniversaries
that I think lead to reflection.
It's the 25th anniversary
of "Don't Speak,"
which is incredible to think
that it's been that long.
Is it as equally sort of
mind-jarring to you
that it has been that long
since that song came out?
-Yes, it is, Seth.
Very, very crazy.
[ Laughs ]
I'm not like a big
anniversary person,
you know what I'm saying?
I feel like everybody
comes to me
and they're like,
"You got to post!"
Like, "It's 25 years of this,"
and I'm like, I don't know
I don't really, like, live m
life looking for the next
birthday or celebration, but
when people did start postin
about "Tragic Kingdom" being
25 years, it really was, like --
I got quite emotional that week.
And the whole
"Don't Speak" thing is --
That song, I owe my whole life
to that song.
Me and my brother wrote
that song together,
and it's just crazy
that a song about heartach
that we actually re-wrote
a song that he wrote
and we made it into that song.
So that song had another lif
before this life,
and it took us around the world.
I mean, it gave me
this entire career,
and it transcended cultura
and language barriers
and it was just
an incredible thing
to have one song that was abou
heartache be able to, like
create this entire,
like, future for me.
So, very grateful,
and very trippy to think
that it's been that long.
-Well, we're all very luck
to be living in this futur
with you,
and it is always
such a delight to see you,
and we can't wait to hear
the song later in the show
-Yay! Thanks for having me
Take care!
-You're welcome.
And congratulations again
to you and Blake.
Gwen's single "Slow Clap"
is out now
and she'll be performing i
later on tonight's show.